let's go marasmus P welcome back to fair
race there's an e update it has sharks
in it this is gonna be awesome and I
thought for sure I had some fishes
alright we're gonna have to go fishing
breasts I just hope there's no one out
there that looks like a penis an octa
penis where's my spear there's a spear
here Brittany come here you [ __ ]
get it cuz this is sorry we're gonna
explore some of those islands later it's
gonna be fantastic
that's my reflection no it's a it's a
starfish
there we go yeah you splatter all you
want [ __ ] not gonna change anything
what are you doing it off my friend
shake shame Shannon that's Shannon you
know chop other kid coming stop it's
Eagles what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's like I kill one and you all just
come my god
alright I'm really hungry I'm gonna have
to save Shannon later but I do have
Lizzy and this is back ladies big once
again I'm it okay I'm not gonna cook you
this because I love I know bears there
you go alright let's cook this fish see
there you go you can almost see it I
thought for sure you got two of them
oh well I'll keep Lizzy as backup food
what did you say to me not I said you're
black and beautiful
okay that's Bella also find this
cassette player I'll show you what it
does later alright now we can eat it
there you go
alright I swear that no what are you
done I'm sorry I didn't pee I thought we
were friends
hoods fight you're French yes of cause
I'm Fred I did oh but I'm sorry Lucy
hey at least let me be delicious
actually I don't even need to eat you
right now are you sick of a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you all did this I
did so I built the door look at I just
need to be old walls and stuff I built
this trap
not gonna go near it because I might die
I built a bowl and you can't build
benches in Moore but now you have a
towel oh god what was that
oh god seagull shut up shut the [ __ ] up
seagulls all right they saw me I think
they saw me [ __ ] all right so they upped
the difficulty a lot from this mmm
job blood oh god dude you're coming
alright go in that let me see I'm going
to fire like him going I thought they're
the ones that saw me so here's the thing
we got that guy he's a Scouter and he
sends its [ __ ] on you and when the
[ __ ] is dead he will go back and alarm
the people so you have to kill the
scowler no wait the [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
alright he's dead I think
alright he's dead what is she doing
stupid ass alright i decapitated him
there you go now what you want to do
when you got a [ __ ] stuck like this you
want to grab his leg and feed it to that
[ __ ] eat it eat it eat it
mother [ __ ] I told you not to get near
my turn what's your last word Laci died
for your sins [ __ ]
what is this stone I actually want that
get throw it at people it's hilarious
look at ya stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] hell it's
like they don't knowing is that more of
them right there
Oh God I better gab order [ __ ] mother of
dicks stains I am going away I'm covered
in blood - this is very bad
Oh God I think they saw that I killed
them and their lot not happy about it
we're gonna have to build some statues
Oh guys ah the [ __ ] is what
yes submarine abilities that's not fair
at all is it alright don't come near me
scared of waters [ __ ] [ __ ] oh and
you can open these now I don't know if
you could do that before you can open
them and there's always a bottle and
cloth but the bottles don't appear so I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do with Oh
God one of them totally saw me what the
[ __ ] what do you guys come from oh god
they're so angry they're sober oh god
there's like a gazillion of them mother
[ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] now I'm so dead oh
god I'm so dead oh god there's sharks
over there okay oh [ __ ]
we can play the seagull killing game
yeah I kill them without him in aiming
499 and 500 wow I sure was an eventful
evening I'm a little worried going back
to my nest we will have to build some
effigies to keep those [ __ ] off my
turf maybe they got lost you know I
can't I won't blame them if they got
lost but if I build the effigies they
know they know not to [ __ ] with me let's
build an effigy here but first we must
play our national anthem
bill that [ __ ] never gave bill
everybody tips keep it every [ __ ] a
few bills at my [ __ ] mg weird a pretty
big empty airline [ __ ] am scared
big that [ __ ] you Bildad
[ __ ] ever Jimmy ever G ever you
build a [ __ ] a big a bill that
[ __ ] after you build a
[ __ ] never Gabriel that
[ __ ] if you build a boat is [ __ ]
if you build a boss [ __ ] same Cubans
ever this [ __ ] hip again fact if you
got winter and flapper girl of worker
definitely but with David he but with a
baby eager lady
dignity dignity
beats me I have no idea what happened
further motive oh hello there sir would
you like to help me be on my motorboat
if you would you like to have with you
my mother phone excuse help me bear
bye-bye forever you will me bill my
mother kept you gonna be lonely if you
add you're ready gonna be a smarty buggy
damage is done what the hell did he go
oh gotta get the head how's the best
song ever you're welcome it's so [ __ ]
quiet now hahahaha where's the dead guy
we need him we need his head hopefully
he drops two heads sometimes they drop
two heads I don't know how that works
alright I'll [ __ ] they're there all
right let's let's see the power of
difference see what we got here
[ __ ] I don't I don't think they liked
okay they did not like it
[ __ ] duck at Amaka tennis ball the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do with you that's
fantastic
oh my ball is still bouncing what the
[ __ ] come back here Jimmy maybe you can
play fetch with a shark or some [ __ ]
so how should we build this like what's
the smartest way to build I'd go for a
basic wall I don't need to defense him
well let's just build that they're done
Lizzy what are you doing stop dick heads
I don't like your calve shut up not
killing you and giving you a home God
all right what is next in our little
output outdoor contract mint you should
probably put a wall here and here let's
do that I swear to god I hear something
from here it's my tennis ball it's been
bouncing here forever
is anyone seeing this I've I made a
mechanism anism
that doesn't exhaust energy my god I
saved the future of mankind I like it
what I did here with a table wall very
fitting indeed very fitting let's put
the last one there all right welcome to
La Casa del pods I'll gather coming you
know what let's go and save here you
were cold and wet built a fighter and to
get hot can I reach the fire from here
oh man I can that's awesome
ah feels great wish I had a ceiling just
I can't see me the best defense ever oh
God
what was that God they found the
Infinity they found me
leave me alone place oh god they're
gonna find in here pretty soon it stop
hitting my fortress [ __ ] I slice you
this is how you play hardcore games got
to make sure she's [ __ ] dead
that's the problem oh Jesus she flew
everywhere right all right you know what
come at me bro I'm [ __ ] tired anymore
I'm gonna build you into a [ __ ] power
how does that feel how does that feel I
said ooh what what no just I crash
anyway alright the game man has the same
now so you can make it out alive even
though the game says [ __ ] you don't
worry lady I would never cut cut cook
you oh yeah is that so yeah it's what I
swear I love you you know what I don't
even care anymore
that's great I love you lazy you're so
funny
no not again use hike huh I swear to God
I didn't mean to do that huh you
son-of-a-bitch
I trust you I try to eat the damn bunny
when I click the wrong oh my god
you better eat these damn Iggy how's
that can't a stone oh god what is that
what was that [ __ ] spider what the
fine Jimmy Chang Chang [ __ ] I think I'm
basedgod thirty oh my dick alright that
dance is badass
and we have a nice little hammer
whenever we need it oh cool so you can
break the rocks with a [ __ ] stick and
then you can throw it at the seagulls
that's amazing and wait for it wait for
it wait for up god damn it oh yes
forever bouncing tennis ball go oh Jesus
it bounces hard tennis ball ain't
playing man there he is again what the
[ __ ] how does how does that work how
alright finally for the millionth time
I've been trying to build this damn boat
huh so let's build the [ __ ] boat this
will be amazing
go tennis ball nother what go away what
pretty look what someone [ __ ] with me
what is going what I'm scared this game
Dan
finalmente whoa my god best boat ever
I'm sailing
we go to the islands said get off my
boat [ __ ] said an open cause for the
vert hypo don't leave me
you got you oh my god so fast this is
has to be faster than sanic man what I'm
Jesus
oh no oh you can't go to the islands is
that it oh that what's the point with a
boat update if that's all you can do
come on I leave you can do with this
what I don't know what's going on I lost
everything
what the hell happened there one last
thing I want to take out I'm gonna
regret this this is stupid
oh no never mind about that so chart
gonna kill it
what has a shot fin can be slin so work
your eyes and maybe you can oh god
they're jumping after me no oh god
blades Jax not me oh god there's so many
what are you doing no gasps stop it stop
it please
ah yeah
you enjoyed that episode go ahead
leaving like to be dead hit subscribe
coma birth today see you in the next
1000 are you